what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get her lunch
money right i'm here with polita
whoever don't forget that low 20s house
spotify block five block five has three
products you can buy and sell crypto on
their crypto exchange with no fees
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar to get your crypto collateral
or you can use my favorite product i'm
an investor i sit on the board and i
love
the interest bearing product you can go
and you can deposit digital dollars or
cryptocurrencies and you can earn up to
eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account go to
who blockfi.compom.com about your dance
let's go
okay um bitcoin slid
to 53 000 and people saying us on sale
you know
something okay it actually fell all the
way down to 46.
okay so relevant news to that janet
yellen is uh saying is saying that they
will remain important questions about
legitimacy and stability
i don't think that bitcoin is widely
used as a transaction mechanism she said
to the extent it is used by fear it's
often used for illicit
finance it's an extremely inefficient
way of conducting transactions
and the amount of energy that's consumed
and processing those transactions
is staggering what do you have to say to
janet
janet yellen doesn't understand bitcoin
and janet yellen should worry about the
stability of the u.s dollar and federal
reserve
and the current incumbent that's what i
think
but but to be fair a lot of reporters
ask her about bitcoin so she has to
answer and that is her opinion right
you know what janet yellen should say i
don't understand this i'm not going to
talk
literally every single thing she said is
inaccurate
factually inaccurate or has been
disproven
over the last couple of years what this
is this is propaganda that's what that's
all that is
that is propaganda that is literally
talking points that are
inaccurate to continue to reinforce a
narrative that is beneficial
to her and her colleagues all right it
is propaganda
and we should call it what it is that is
absolute nonsense we should not allow
and reporters should call it out and say
janet yellen said xyz xyz
is not true it is provably inaccurate
and the fact that they continue to
answer the questions and
and publish the information as if it is
accurate is intellectually lazy
on the reporter's standpoint two the
publications are not doing their job in
terms of fact checking
and three stop asking her questions we
know she's gonna spew propaganda
go ahead indian billionaire who is
referred to
often as uh the warren buffett of india
uh rakesh genjawala i think uh he said
the country's regulator should ban
cryptocurrency such as bitcoin he said
he will never buy bitcoin he said i
think it's speculation of the highest
order
i don't want to join every party in town
i think the hangover is much
worse how do you make his money how did
he make his money
yeah google up real quick how did he
make his money
let's see how rakesh i think is how you
pronounce it
let's see how he made his money he
he earned eight 1986
uh-huh he had bought five thousand
shares of tata tea at
at 43 okay so he's an investor
and the stock rose to 143 within three
months that's great
okay what what else go here let's give
it to him over three times okay so he's
an investor
congratulations um his biggest
investment
oh wow you're a gambler that's what you
do for a living you're
very volatile you're a gambler that's
what you do you go to the casino
and you literally are betting on black
or red over and over again
on the future outcome of something that
you have no control over
that's what you are well maybe you might
be good at it you're a billionaire
congratulations i'm so proud of you
but you're a gambler and gambler's gonna
gamble so don't talk about
oh they're speculating no what you're
saying is you don't understand that game
so you
aren't going to go play that game by the
way that makes you an intelligent
gambler you understand your circle of
competence you're going to stay within
it
but let's not get it confused they
should write an article it says
gambler because that's what you're doing
you're going to the stock market which
is the casino and you are gambling
on the future outcome of an asset
that you have no control over so if we
want to start being real savages up in
here
we're going to start calling people out
so okay i'm glad that you're a
billionaire
but you're a gambler so don't call oh
they're speculating
you speculate every day yeah well so his
stocks fell by up to 30
in december of 2011. he recovered his
losses in february 2012
these ups and downs forced him to reduce
his vulnerability
by trimming his portfolio to one third
he's also known as the king of the bull
market
oh okay the king of the bull market
got left behind because instead of
holding the stocks if you held bitcoin
he would actually perform better
so rakesh i probably would be your
friend your friend
we probably could go grab a beer
together but i just want you to know
that you're gambling and you played the
wrong game
this is a straw man argument why are you
going after him and not saying that his
position
is false around bitcoin you're attacking
what he's done in the past
because his argument is garbage it's
like it's literally like a gambler
saying oh i don't gamble over there
no you that's literally what you do for
a living is you gamble
alright it says he said i think
regulators should step in and ban
bitcoin and they should focus on the
digital
rupee okay well that's interesting
what i will say last thing rakesh if you
want to outperform your stock
performance sell all your stocks and buy
bitcoin you'll do better off
this is not financial advice not
financial advice that no that's just me
and him talking directly i know
somebody's gonna send him this
by the way call me i'll talk to you i'll
teach you he'll be friends with rick
kashmir no we won't be friends
i absolutely know we would be friends
because i could see it
in the stories like i see it in the
blood i know exactly the type of person
that he is him and i would get along
i choose to play a different game than
he plays but we're both playing games so
let's just get on the phone and we'll
talk
plus i need more indian billionaire
friends
wework co-founder and former ceo adam
newman is an advanced
talks to settle a high-profile legal
fight with softbank by agreeing to
nearly a 500
million million dollar 500 million
dollar cut in his payout
from the shared office space company's
new owner
a move that would help clear the way for
wework's second attempt
at a public listing oh there's so much
in this store
i like this move why get them in the pub
markets
i actually think that if we work was
managed correctly it could be a great
business it's a great idea
it's obvious that the market wants it
now with all the remote work and all
that stuff people
have the need for short-term office
leases
but with all the drama between wework
and their biggest investor softbank
there was a ton of
and it's still continuing the
negotiations have been rocky at times
and there is no guarantee
they will produce an agreement i wrote
about it this morning everyone would you
everyone wants to not about this
specifically everyone wants to live in
the extreme
binary world wework's not going to zero
we work also it's probably not gonna a
thousand x from here
something in between is gonna happen the
extreme of adam newman's gonna get all
his money
or the extreme of adam newman's gonna
get none of his money are both wrong
it's gonna be somewhere in between
everyone chill out take a deep breath
wework's a good idea it's obvious the
market needs it it's obvious that they
got
revenue it's obviously that it's working
in terms of the product
so they got to figure out some of the
financial stuff the guys
management yeah they just they go clean
it up don't worry don't worry don't
worry everybody calm down
use this as a digital receipt when they
get it worked out you all going to come
back and be like i think they're going
public via spec i mean i think they will
my guy masa do anything all right
lucid motors deal so electric vehicle
startup lucid
plans to go public through a reverse
merger with a blank
blank check company i.e a spec
started by veteran investment banker
michael klein
cool well the problem is that the spak
shares fell almost 50 yeah the hell
here's why so a spec goes out public at
ten dollars
and it traded up and it traded up and it
traded up and it traded up and it traded
up and it traded up and it traded
and it traded up and it traded up all
the way to almost
40 something dollars they don't got any
company
how's it forty dollars how did it forex
yeah how did it what are they buying
it's because the deal leaked because
people were speculating
rakesh listen speculating on the fact
that they were going to buy this company
and so it's straight up traded up traded
up traded up traded up
and then the second the second that
people saw the actual financials of the
business
and told my son all right fell 50 so the
whole key is you can't have the deals
leak and
maybe you guys should chill out let them
do the deals first then
actually make your investment decisions
i thought i was going to sneeze i don't
have to sneeze now
macy's anthony
macy you're so annoying now that people
are gonna take this and there's gonna be
memes of you you guys should mean that
no you should not be if you meme it i
may retweet it
don't do it maybe don't do it maybe he
won't retweet it
he'll actually delete it and block it
okay uh
the pandemic has slammed macy's and
other big retailers really
badly but macy said tuesday that it
turned a
profit for the very first time in the
pandemic making 160 million dollars
during the 13 weeks ending on january
30th down from 340 million
during the same stretch a year ago dang
first time it made money in the pandemic
yet that is still
more than half uh less than it did last
year at this time
there's pent up consumer demand and when
they open the floodgates
like a tsunami let's roll but we're not
there yet so
okay let's ask lunch money time ask
l and in the comments below ask me
questions too guys
not about my hair all right um
baldo granados what are your favorite
fast food restaurants
go ahead mcdonald's and chick-fil-a
mcdonald's the best restaurant in
america hands down period consistent
low cost on every street corner mainly a
better restaurant you can't
so moist tracker day
today is day nine um natron by the way
says i picture moist
looking like shaggy from scooby doo i
kind of do too for some reason i don't
know why
how do you picture him looking
how do you picture him looking moist and
i got a good relationship right now so
he asked me no crazy questions moist
day 8 of commenting on every episode of
lunch money until pump gives me a call
the origin story behind the voice name
isn't super crazy
i made this account when i was 13
originally as moist
kyogre i think to comment on pokemon
videos wow
throwback moist makes a lot of people
uncomfortable and i thought
slash still think that's hilarious and
also kyogre
is a water type pokemon so it worked
after a while i got into other areas of
youtube and the internet so i dropped
the kyogre
part your moist i think that's i think
that's funny too moist does make people
comfortable
uncomfortable uncomfortable if you if
you go to a restaurant you're out with a
bunch of people and you just say hey
guys
moist oh yeah i see like really easy how
about how about this
moist ointment
okay um anyway so i just hate both of
them how does that what goes on in your
head no that's a weird word voice looks
like another question for you
when you tie your shoes do you tie your
shoes
loop in swoop or bunny ears do not screw
this up
if you tie your shoes the wrong way deal
break i do loop and swoop
i'm not gonna reveal how i do it looping
swoop or bunny ears
leave it in the comments moist and if
you do it wrong
we won't have trouble all right guys
that's it for lunch money today
moist we'll talk soon hopefully see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest
on an interest-bearing account or you
can buy and sell cryptocurrencies on
their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends